now I didn't know all these things so N
Dash is for nut and then M Dash the M is
for mutton yeah this is like super geeky
stuff if you're ever on Jeopardy and you
win a prize for a typographic question
like this I think you need to send a
check over to Charles for helping you
out with this because that is super good
I feel smarter already
Charles Charles would slay on Jeopardy I
think
in design there's no excuses man look
this is where you don't want to bring
the bad boy out of me it's early today
so let's don't drag this out of me
hello beautiful people what's up we're
going to be talking about typography
today and it's our collaboration with
monotype monotype and the future and
we're going to be celebrating The Life
and Times of the late and great Virgil
ablo who passed away last year and that
was inspiration behind today's work this
assignment that we put out to our
community and a little bit about
off-white as a brand it's defined as the
gray area between black and white as the
color off-white and Virgil's done some
amazing collaborations with Brands like
Levi's Montclair Nike Warby Parker and
Ikea and he was started off this vision
for a company a short-lived t-shirt
brand called Pyrex that led him to
bigger and greater things he's known as
a multi-disciplinary designer and some
of his background he's studied civil
engineering of all things at the
University of Wisconsin then he got his
master's degree in architecture at the
Illinois Institute of Technology the
reason why I share that is because that
background his education informs some of
the aesthetic and design decisions he's
made as this iconic fashion designer in
part part of it is about deconstructing
and reconstructing youth culture graphic
design art history semiotics and luxury
so the assignment for our students here
was to design an A1 format poster for a
theoretical traveling exhibition to
Showcase some of its most iconic work
and so each student was able to pick
something that inspired them and then
draw from that and deconstruct that and
interpret that as a poster that in
theory would be hang hanging on a wall
or surrounding the exhibit of the piece
itself some of the requirements for the
assignment as it came from the brief was
that you have to use all this text you
have to use the word ubiquity which is
closely tied to the general
philosophical concepts of Virgil's work
the word deconstruction and breaking
boundaries that's a clue is a hint as to
maybe some conceptual directions to go
in of course Virgil's name and these
cities and countries Paris China Tokyo
Japan and United States and the address
Etc and in case you're unfamiliar with
some of his work where you been by the
way here's some some work that's from
his very creative and fertile mind you
can see the use of the stripes and
drawing very much from Street vernacular
and just kind of using uh the language
of non-design and finding a way for it
to integrate into high design and so
there's a lot of really cool things that
are happening here and let's see I'm
just eagerly looking forward to seeing
what our design students have come up
with this is also part of the brand
identity system I suppose with off-white
and you can see the four pointed arrows
these striped lines which are very
prevalent in in his work and and just
kind of like this this calling things
for what they are like putting things in
quote like a belt being called a belt or
a label or a handle there's something
really interesting about that and before
I go on any further don't forget to like
comment and subscribe to the channel and
I'm going to introduce the two
instructors the R2 very esteemed
instructors from monotype first up is
Terence weinzero he's a creative type
director at monotype studio uh Terence
has been creating and modifying
typefaces for the monotype library and a
wide range of Brands since 2008 in
addition to working on custom projects
for PBS Microsoft Google Barnes and
Noble dominoes and sap he's designed
type for video games professional sports
teams and auto manufacturers and also is
joining us is Charles Nix he's a
creative type director designer
typographer and educator he's designed a
number of popular typefaces in the
monotype library including walbum and
hope stands which received a certificate
of typographic excellence in the 22nd
annual type directors Club
congratulations he's also designed
custom typefaces for Google Noto
Progressive Insurance in the
Philadelphia Museum of Art gentlemen
welcome to the show and without further
Ado maybe I should just have you guys
say hello first yeah of course thanks
thanks for introducing us and um yeah
great to be here looking forward to it
wonderful yeah likewise it's
um it's a pleasure to be here with You
Chris and it's great to see all of this
work and to be able to comment on it I
have to say Charles I'm a little scared
shared we were talking about this before
the show I'm a little scared because
I've never had two amazing professional
type typographers instructors and
designers to join me on this so I'm
scared for myself I'm scared for our
students I wonder how this is all gonna
go I gotta tell you that it's always
been my experience with typographers
true typographers that there are very
generous lot we all know as as Matthew
Carter has want to say that we're our
work is built on the work of those who
came before us we stand on the shoulders
of giants and so paying it forward in
any way that we can is part of what we
do so don't be afraid
well I'll start it off easy for sure I
think so okay so we're gonna ramp up
perhaps I think so yeah okay this is
wonderful so Terence has chosen uh three
students or three work uh three pieces
of work to look at and that's how we're
gonna do uh this is how we're gonna hold
today's session uh each instructor has
chosen three pieces I know there are a
lot more submissions than those but it's
just a matter of time and what we can do
so we're going to hopefully spend more
uh time critiquing fewer people so that
there are more opportunities for us to
learn and I hope that all of you even if
you didn't participate can get some
value from this just keep in mind this
is not officially sanctioned by anybody
except for monotype in the future this
is purely for student and learning
purposes so we're using copyright
infringement we respect all the
copyright holders there just saying that
I'm probably gonna get sued anyways but
um there I've said it okay a couple
other things that you need to be aware
of the files that you sent over you
followed under instruction questions
almost perfectly they're just massive
the files are massive there's in the
files I opened up hundreds of layers and
everybody builds files in their own way
so we're gonna probably not be able to
get under the hood as much as I normally
would because there's just so many
complex layers here as be fitting with a
project like this if construction and
deconstruction for virtual blow okay the
three people that you chose Terence are
Ahmed adani and viksha so without
further Ado I'm gonna stop my share and
turn this over to you we'll start with
the Ahmed first here and one more thing
yeah just to reiterate you know what
Mark said thank thank you for the
participants for for sending in the work
yeah it's a privilege to to do these
sort of critiques and so just by you
spending your time you know creating new
work just for a special event like this
tells me that you are spending your time
practicing and and trying to get better
uh and I I admire that quality so Props
to you so yeah the first piece here I
love the focus on type obviously I think
helvetica enjoys being used like this
like helvetica feels comfortable in this
setting and some people say that red is
like the typographer's second favorite
color after black so that's yeah
obviously red white and black is you
know very powerful you know color
palette kind of that stands out to me
right away there's a lot of white space
and I'll get into maybe why that's a
good thing or a bad thing or why it's
why it's hard to balance that much white
space I think but the first thing that
that really stands out is all of this
kind of movement and disturbance to the
type that's already happening here with
the the dots from the eyes falling off
and becoming um you know elements of you
know eye movement and kind of adding to
the the composition as a whole just why
these little tiny black dots so I think
that's a very kind of sophisticated use
of that uh deconstruction there um and
then I think the hierarchy is nice here
too because I think it's just his name
is front and center the scale change to
the dates and how this kind of bleeds
off to the edge has kind of nice timing
to it and then of course like you you're
pointing out with these kind of graphic
elements from the off-white brand with
these kind of jarring like warning
Stripes that you would see from you know
a blocked Street we're trained to see
those stripes as a stop as a way to stop
so I think that's why he uses those you
know graphic elements I think the script
typeface on the bottom adds a lot of
richness to it because it's the only use
of it there so everything is Stark and
um and organized and then you just get
that one twist uh that surprise of that
script typeface it reminds me of you
know like the video clips of Virgil
using a marker to write these quotes
around stuff and remind people to think
twice about what they're looking at as a
way you know a good artist does I think
so I think that's a nice use of of the
type of air without without repeating it
and then of course you get this block of
information at the bottom which is kind
of a poster habit you know I think for a
good reason you get the you know kind of
dates and times just at the bottom so I
think that's kind of just a natural
place for those things to be there one
thing I would think about changing if I
were to explore this differently is that
this suitcase is kind of small and
hidden in comparison and it adds a
little mystery to the poster but I wish
it were larger like I could see some
variations of this poster with
um more focus on image and I think
that's the part I'm questioning like is
there too much white space is there too
much negative space maybe it depends on
the audience or the media type one thing
that came up when I was reviewing all
these posters was what type of media or
how long would the viewer have to see
this poster so it's sort of like the
billboard test can you tell what it's
about only looking at it for three
seconds or is it a type of poster that's
on the side of a bus stop where you
might have a viewer that gets five
minutes with it the difficulty with with
posters in particular is like how much
information do you put on them if it's
too much it'll turn people off and they
won't read any of it and if it's not
enough is it is it too mysterious some
people will freak out about letters
touching each other I don't and I don't
think it's really a problem in
particular with like handwritten
typefaces or scripts like this but just
as like professional practice be
prepared for another art director or
maybe you know a marketing person tell
you not to have letters overlapping
Chris or Charles you have anything to
add before I move to the next one the
dash between 1980 and 2021 should be an
end as instead of a hyphen that's just a
straight up typographic Basics I would
like to see in the listing of place
names I would like to see them separated
by periods rather than commas because it
makes it seem in this particular setting
like there's some they're adding up to
something but it's not an and and an end
it's just a Paris period Tokyo period
China period but otherwise yeah I like
in this one particularly the way that
that those three bits of information
have been relegated because as you'll
see in the posters that I'm critiquing
that they take on undue stress sometimes
yeah I really enjoyed the way that you
spoke about this and it's always
interesting to hear other designers and
typographers break things down how you
talk about the Rhythm and the the
falling of the dots for the eyes and
also just the structure at the bottom
now with the design like this it feels
like you understand how to lay things
out follow grid system and work with
negative space and then one of the
reasons why we chose off-white and
virgilo not in just celebrating his life
but because of the way he he looked at
construction and deconstruction and so
one of the parameters of this assignment
was to incorporate a three-dimensional
element whether it's implied with
Photoshop or whatever because of limited
resources or if you've actually done
something to add that extra element and
I'm not seeing it here or at least to
maybe play around with the themes of
deconstruction and so you chose the I
think this this luggage and I'm thinking
what else can be done with the luggage
to incorporate that versus hiding it
behind this the red stripes one thing is
if we think about luggage it's being
trailed around on Wheels and it picks up
dirt and what if some of that the tracks
from the wheels were run across your
poster so that when you're seeing this
in an exhibition you're incorporating
some of the elements so it feels as if
the luggage rolled across the poster and
dropped down in front of you maybe
there's something like that I also think
about the visual language the vernacular
of travel or at least the way it used to
be you have tags you have destinations
like LAX and different cities and and
maybe you can use the abbreviations to
suggest something like that I also think
about those sticky labels that they put
around your luggage with the barcode and
borrowing from that visual language I
think bringing that in would have
possibly taken this to that next level
we've seen a lot of really beautiful
Swiss modern typographic exploration
before this is one of those
opportunities for you really go get
crazy because you're ultimately just
working with one poster and to really
have a lot of fun I have a question for
Charles since you brought this up there
are a couple different types of dashes
right there's a hyphen which is I think
just the minus symbol then there's an
end Dash is that the option minus sign
and then there's that M Dash which is
option shift minus sign and there are
different lengths one is short one is
medium and one is really long so Charles
being the resident type nut what do you
use for What occasion just so that we
can use this as a learning opportunity
hyphenating
um you use a hyphen the simple sort of
short Dash and that you use the
hyphenate words hyphenate names
hyphenate breaks at the end of sentences
or end of lines of type then end dashes
are to indicate an omission of a range
of of data so if I want to say from the
Year 1980 to 2021 and I don't want to
write out all the dates in between I
insert an N Dash there so option hyphen
it's a slight difference but the N Dash
is half the point size so if you're
using 12 point type the N Dash is six
points wide the M Dash and I'm sorry but
they're both uh you know sort of
confusingly named and in metal type they
would refer them to them as the nut and
as mutton to try and differentiate them
but the M Dash is used to sort of set
off parenthetical text or parenthetical
thought and by parenthetical it's sort
of like anything you would put inside of
parentheses you can separate with an M
Dash instead so em as in mud and I use M
dashes quite a bit because as you
probably will gather over the course of
this critique session I speak quite
parenthetically quite often so I in that
sentence I just gave to you and as it
continues there would be probably 15 M
dashes because I keep speaking in
parentheses nested inside of parentheses
so there you know these are the sort of
fine points of typography that all
typographers who are of a certain ilk
know and sort of they live
um and Virgil actually plays on this
idea when he uses quotes around things
like ubiquity he uses primarks instead
as a sort of wink to everyone who knows
that those are the wrong things that
he's using the wrong thing because it's
a way of creating that kind of agreement
between high and low if I was a
secretary I might be prone to using
prime marks but as a professional
designer I use quote marks and so I'm
showing you the wrong thing so that you
understand we are in agreement wow that
was wonderful and what about spacing
before and after using these dashes are
is it meant to be used without any
spacing at all generally speaking no
spaces no spaces around any of them but
in the 60s I think it was the 60s yanchi
gold created this series of rules for
typesetting for penguin the classic
penguin classic uh books but he asked
the penguin compositors to do was to set
n dashes en the nut instead of mutton
the mutt or the M Dash and he won it's
small spaces on either side of the end
spaces because he felt that M dashes
were so big you know 12 point M Dash is
12 points long that he just wanted a
more brief moment to set off
parenthetical thought so in those cases
there you know he was suggesting a very
specific amount of space around the the
end Dash but a lot of Swank Smart
typographers in the 21st century will
use regular spaces around n dashes
instead of an M Dash wow yeah and I
would add to that too it might depend on
the typeface and and the designer who
made it I think you know like Charles
said we kind of we design our typefaces
kind of like a house style if you will
without the need for spacing but you
might find a variance in that just
throughout all of the fonts everywhere
so uh you know if you just use it at
your at your discretion and the more
experienced you are the better you will
be at recognizing when that space needs
to change or not I just want to point
out how is that medically pleasing oh
before you zoom out like how excited
aesthetically pleasing just that just
framing was with the red and the type to
the side and cutting things off right it
looks really good before I get it to
everything that Charles just dropped on
us
um all this information so part of this
whole idea of deconstruction is we we
might want to design something and then
we need to step away maybe print it out
and play around with the materials and
cut things up and really have fun if we
stay within the confines of the the
toolbox that we're working with InDesign
illustrator Photoshop whatever your tool
of choice is it tends to dictate the way
that we think about things so really let
loose crop things zoom in tear things up
break things apart and really have fun
with this now I didn't know all these
things so N Dash is for nut and then M
Dash the M is for mutton yeah this is
like super geeky stuff if you're ever on
Jeopardy and you win a prize for a
typographic question like this I think
you need to send a check over to Charles
for helping you out with this because
that is super good next thing he said
was that the N Dash is half the point
size of the typeface in terms of its
width right correct I didn't know that
either so a 12 point type set will have
a six point wide N Dash and a 12 point
because a double M Dash or mutton I feel
smarter already
Charles Charles would slay on Jeopardy I
think
[Laughter]
yeah this is very good okay Ahmed you're
here are there any things that you want
to respond or ask before we move on to
the next person thank you so much just
uh regarding the the the the suitcase
originally I wanted to because this is
the suitcase for me it represents
deconstruction and breaking the
boundaries because we were not used to
to looking at a transparent suitcase so
originally I wanted to put something
behind it and maybe try to make that
show from behind but but I didn't know
how to do it technically so so that's
why I I kind of used the the red stripes
to achieve the same thing and also as a
nod to the Kanye West the album cover
that's the idea behind those tribes and
thank you so much guys for all for all
the feedback yes you're welcome uh
Terence and Charles this idea of a
transparent suitcase was lost on me this
whole like I couldn't tell so if you
wanted to play around with transparency
what what suggestions do you have for
Ahmed when you just go go to effects in
the right hand palette there and you
know add that at the transparency
through multiply but I love the idea
that that suitcase now
um thinking of it I was thinking of it
poetically as sort of like Gone Too Soon
sort of maybe metaphor but um but the
idea of it being a transparent suitcase
which was completely lost on me just
opens up all kinds of creative
possibilities and the fact that it's
it's roughly the proportions of your
poster it's like why not have the entire
poster in the suitcase it would be so so
cool like a great framing device the
original photo of the of the suitcase I
couldn't find it in a higher on high
enough resolution so I also had to keep
it small enough ten thousand dollars to
buy a suitcase just for this project
come on there's almost commitment here
man in the olden days we would take
advantage of that sort of limitation of
the scale of a of a photograph and blow
it up in the case of pixelation or in
the case of dot patterns just that's
pretty that's plenty good actually yeah
the entire design I found a highway
I'm too late but can you can you imagine
if you took this out of the digital
sphere and and sort of and printed it
and then were able to either through a
transparency or through a silk screen or
through any other method to put that
suitcase on top of it instead of both a
foreground and background a transparent
and or you know a dominant but recessive
thing would be really really cool I
don't have access to such abilities so I
mean I'm going to cut in here in design
and there's no excuses man look this is
where you don't want to bring the bad
boy out of me it's early today so let's
don't drag this out of me what we want
to do is we want to hear ideas and
either you did it or you didn't not
reasons why you could not yeah but as
soon as you do that I'm going to go into
the Hulk mode and say you could have
just bought some press down type put it
on pieces of Plexi so that you know
there's creativity Charles is saying is
use constraints to your advantage don't
sit there and say a handcuff I couldn't
do this you could print things out on
acetate everybody has the opportunity to
do that and you can tape them together I
always think what a wonderful aesthetic
that would be because of the edges you
know if you printed this out like actual
size and worked with it there's so many
things that you can do okay just process
the information because this is an
invitation for you to play and not be
limited by what you can or cannot do at
least in your mind the next one on my
list was uh viksha here a whole nother
ballpark
um the first I mean the first thing that
stands out to me is it really the you
know the darkness the richness the depth
of this uh swirled
snarled kind of fabric in the background
um and it becomes very powerful
especially with that intense
um red as as the second color you know I
was talking about the billboard test is
like what is it what does it look like
with just three seconds of a glance and
I think the fabric makes me think of
fashion kind of right away so I think
that is that's a strength of this is
that you know that that image you know
makes me you know understand what it's
going to be before I look too too too
long at it and so I think there's
there's obviously a very you know
powerful uh focal point with this kind
of swirl going on at the top and there's
but there's a few different elements
that are kind of dragging you along to
other focal points so I think that the
hierarchy with with the size is in place
there it's kind of um the hierarchy has
Disturbed Itself by the color choices so
I think what's happening is that you get
this very strong focal point right here
in the center because of these these
Swirls and then you get this black black
text on kind of a black background which
makes it you know very hard to read it's
good and bad again has has a mystery and
you have to look longer in order to be
in order to read it I think the the part
that bothers me is that these just the
list of places becomes number one in the
hierarchy because of the size and the
color and I think that might be a
misstep because the city names are kind
of the least important or one of the
least important pieces of information so
I kind of struggle with that like is
this hierarchy serving it well or not
but I think you know moving on to the
other focal points is that you get you
know Virgil's name uh in the middle here
um and then you get a third kind of
treatment here the part that I'm
questioning is sort of like is it too
much is there too many uh different
elements that are competing for the for
the focal point and for the attention
here maybe I think I would love to see
it like without the
um without the red polygon
um just because there's all you already
have a lot of the composition structure
is already made with the fabric I think
I would have liked to see you kind of
integrate that as a goes to putting
other compositional elements on top of
the fabric that's already there so I
think there's a little bit of things
competing for your for your attention
here I feel like these round swirl Parts
uh you know type on a curve here they
feel a little more integrated because
I'm getting these other round shapes in
the background
um and then this this kind of hard Edge
uh boundary thing as an anchor here
maybe that is just a way to attach these
words to that that visual element as an
anchor where I think they could have
been anchored along these wrinkles and
stuff in other ways and then one more
piece with the the hierarchy is that you
know the brand names are kind of just
tucked away in the corner almost to be
in invisible again maybe the the brand
names of off-white and the the Louis
Vuitton parent company here maybe those
aren't you know very important piece of
information but it feels a little
strange that they're that they're kind
of tucked all the way in the corner it
does kind of support this very strong
kind of uh you know diagonal composition
that kind of swirls into this focal
point but they feel kind of haphazard I
think a little bit having his birth and
death date underneath the brand name is
real weird because it seems like that
like this is the birth and death of the
Louis Vuitton brand because those two
elements are side by side they get
grouped mentally that way so I that's a
that's a misstep I think there but
otherwise I think
um I really have to give bonus points
um to to viksha here because of using
you know uh this Fabric and even just a
very simple uh you know photography
method your your smartphone can take
this take this image uh you know quickly
I think smartphone cameras are so good
these days you have less need for a
scanner a lot of people have powerful
cameras in their pocket in order to do
you know even very simple kind of
photographs like this so you guys want
to chip in on this one too or I think
Terence covered a a lot of ground here
this is a poster to me that seems like
it's got four or five really solid ideas
going on in it but and any one of them
maybe it's five separate posters but any
one of them could have carried the day
like that that fabric is as Taryn says
just a it's just a brilliant
um Trope like if if you if you
subjugated the or
um subverted or pushed down the rest of
the information in the poster and just
let Virgil hang out there in the middle
it's such a poetic testimony to a life
cut short and you know it it Intimates a
lot without without having to say it
overtly if you got rid of the fabric you
could move that trapezoid into a
completely you know separate Trope that
creates its own great poster but they're
just too many things layered on top of
one another here this typeface has
lining numerals so lining numerals are
are numbers that all have the same width
so if we look at 1980 and 2001 it looks
like 980-202 are hanging out together
nice and chummy in the middle there and
then the ones are just these Outsiders
and that's because they're exactly the
same width as the nine and the eight and
the zero and the two so when you
encounter something like this it's
incumbent upon you as a typographer to
to bring it back into into shape so
tighten up the space between the one the
nine give a little more breath between
the eight and the zero possibly touch
the space between the nine and the eight
but you know create Rhythm there and
then if you look at that poor little
hyphen and that hyphen is centered on
that x height because it's meant to be
used in lower case and uppercase
settings but these are essentially
capitals so it's floating down to the
bottom it looks like it's sinking so
replacing with an endash will help a
little bit because it will raise it up
slightly in most typefaces but you're
going to have to do a little bit extra
to raise it up to fit in the cap height
of those figures but these are you know
these are tiny things that allow
Virgil's audience to understand that
they're looking at a clash of high and
low cultures as opposed to something
that doesn't really understand its its
quality or its Essence way to always
zoom in on those details Charles so as a
person who designs typefaces what is the
reasoning I think I know why but what is
the reason why these are spaced this way
so that it it makes it difficult for us
who are not in in accounting dealing
with these numbers like you hit on it
right that they're called tabular
figures because they line up in tables
so if I was setting an annual report
they would be my best friend and they're
born out of a time when people became
obsessed with Accounting in the 19th
century and they've stayed with us as
the sort of de facto figure style
um because the computer was not meant to
be a typesetting machine at first we
bent it into that shape in the 80s but
um but now it is our type setting
machine so you know these are the kind
of it's the kind of history and sad
details that you need to to um be aware
of as a as a true typographer we you
know here you're looking at ones that
are actually fit so there are lots of
different figure types and you can
access them as you're saying here
through the open type features palette
yeah and I can I can walk through these
but tabular lining the lining part means
that it is it's tall usually cap height
um old style is the ones that bounce up
and down that are designed for right to
be to harmonize with the lower case and
like Charles said this is a this is
proportional this should have tabular
there it goes so that yeah all these are
the same uh the same width across there
and then kind of just to throw to throw
you a monkey wrench is that the you know
there's a there's a default figure there
too so even if a font has all four of
these particular you know type Styles
one of them has to be the default which
is what shows up when you touch the
keyboard and the other ones it come as
alternates so I think before the year
2000 maybe you know most font had
tabular
lining or tabular figures as default and
then I think after 2000 more designers
and foundries were putting proportional
lining figures as default because most
people weren't setting tables with them
like setting figures in text is way more
common than doing a table for financial
results or something so I think it's you
know an 80 20 rule right it's the you
know the lining figures are going to be
used uh most often and so those are kind
of the new default as it were now your
drawing our attention to a couple
different things and perhaps is why
we're talking to folks from monotype is
because not all fonts are created with
this kind of care and attention to have
so many options are also take into
consideration the little bit of default
spacing that might be added to an M or
an N Dash depending on the preferences
right so it's kind of interesting when
you type this up it just looked good and
I wasn't even aware until Charles
brought up like hey the other typeface
you're using either you haven't
activated it or perhaps it didn't allow
you to that option and now that these
kinds of tools are in the hands of
designers if we're going to call
ourselves a designer and hold our head
high we need to be aware of these things
whether it's default setting or not or
if there's even an option we just got to
go in and fix those things right I have
some thoughts on this the first thought
is if I walk by this poster and I squint
it looks like all black to me the red
against the heavy black and that shade
of red it just makes it really really
difficult to read and so I might just
walk past this and you as a designer
your job is to get people to pay
attention without being annoying and I
I'm not sure what the inspiration for
this is but there are has already been
said lots of things that are going on
they're not exactly working in unison
and that's one of those problems where
you want to come up with one Central
powerful idea and don't don't be afraid
to stand confident with that idea and
allow that to speak for me as has been
pointed out this idea of some kind of
fabric or Texture or material that lives
on top of something is really cool but
it's not used to full effect here it
just feels like textural and and
background fodder instead of being the
hero I say this is your most unique and
interesting idea in this poster
exploration here's what I would have
loved for you to do design a beautiful
poster with type all over it and then
print this thing out on a sheet of
plastic that it's got some give to it
and so that you can lay it on top of
something else and my my thought is if
you were to cut out the words words
habla or off or white or anything like
that and lay this on so that the form
the letter forms themselves can create a
dimensional component to it so
integrating all the different ideas
together and that's what I'm looking for
uh or maybe it's like a a piece of
plastic that you apply type on and then
you vacuum form it on top of another
object and so you're you're adding this
Dimension how it bends and wraps would
be very fascinating for me to look at
and would also achieve the requirement
of adding a three-dimensional component
could you imagine walking through a
gallery space and then there was this
component of dimensionality to it how
could you not spend time investigating
it further and that's your job as a
designer last one Donnie cranus so this
one is way more
um playful and and cheerful than than
the last poster and I think I I like to
juxtapose these two together because
um well first of all because the yellow
is so is so cheery what I really respond
to right away with with this poster is
the balance of this kind of black frame
along with this big centered chunk kind
of gives it some stability but then it
has all of this other active stuff going
on so you you have a lot of active
elements that are balanced by the kind
of the the centeredness of it and it you
get these kind of big margins which is a
calming effect you know kind of visually
and the big black frame if you were to
you know crop the the the black frame
off it would be much more active it
would only be active so I think I think
this is a nice balance of something that
is is is both active and calm at the
same time and and kind of uh balance
each other out so I think that's that's
really well done
um the second piece is that the
hierarchy feels good there's there's
good type in this and I think
um you obviously have the you know big
kind of off-white uh headline in the
middle that's kind of reflecting and and
twisting off of itself
um and then again with kind of the the
poster block of information at the
bottom
um and uh what I like about this is that
it's
um there is different type Styles
different weights being used here and it
adds to the texture without being uh too
distracting or too loud to upset the
hierarchy with the other size and color
that's dominating above it so I think
what's what's well done here and what we
didn't see in the other posters is that
both Virgil's name and the date are
contained in these rectangles which will
kind of visually group these two pieces
together so that tells me that the date
belongs to him
um and so I think that is that's a
successful combination here and also
kind of formally is that these
rectangles are you know similar
proportions to these rectangles so we
have a really nice repetition of big
rectangles and it gets to little
rectangles and then it even repeats
again with a little tiny rectangle in
this little tiny kind of favorite icon
looking thing even though this probably
isn't their you know brand guidelines or
something but it I I don't really care I
mean it just it's just such a nice
little detail that again kind of
reflects the other uh you know formal
shapes that are kind of bouncing around
you could replace this with a real logo
and it would feel right there
um so that's a nice nice detail and then
you have kind of you know heavier
weights on the side on a lighter piece
on this side so this even this little
um you know rectangular chunk of
information has a tilt to it because the
left side is heavy and the light side is
right or the right side is light so that
that kind of um weight difference kind
of adds uh you know an eye movement to
it by itself so I like those
combinations
um now I think what is
a little weird or what I don't like
about this is this big kind of
artificial
um
uh drop shadow on here and you know this
little ticker tape is not a bad idea of
a way of like listing the the dates and
times it reminds me of like a lanyard or
uh like a a banner or something like
that so I think the the concept of how
to treat those names is nice but uh this
kind of distorted like really harsher
drop shadow just kind of takes me out of
the moment and it just
um I just I think it just feels like
it's very digitally made kind of right
away so that that takes me out of the
moment but I do like how you know
compositionally you have one on both
sides and it kind of you know
exaggerates the tilt of the type in the
center so you get this nice diagonal
movement all the way across the page
here with again the nice frame to kind
of uh Shore it up a little bit now again
like if we had another 40 hours to work
on this poster you know this would have
been fantastic too uh to print and
um to print into little banners of paper
or something and and photograph them
um you know with with real shadows and
stuff that would make this uh much more
rich and
um you know much more complex to look at
um
but so those are the kind of corner
pieces and then finally you get you know
along the hierarchy stack we get a
little sprinkle of the the kind of the
the sub head and the deconstruction and
breaking boundaries so I think those I
think this is a pretty nice scale change
um kind of throughout
um and looks like it's you know ready to
ready to go for that that particular
size this media size those are all my my
first impressions
anything else do you guys want to add I
just want to acknowledge that you're
very good at this sandwich technique I
have to say
there's a lot of bread and tomatoes
pickles and and Dijon mustard and you
you do a wonderful job I have to learn a
couple things from you because usually
I'm just going like this is garbage I'm
messing this is but I'm just saying
you're doing a good job there okay back
over to you Charles
um one of I mean there are there are a
lot of things in this that I would not
do which is not to say that they're bad
but they're just not things that I would
do the choices and combinations and
weights and stuff with the with the
typefaces they're all over the place but
the way that the poster hangs together
is as a result of the compositional
sense is is really I think something
that almost everybody could um on this
call could learn from including myself
like it's so much easier to organize one
thing on a page than it is to organize
20 things on a page I mean I think we
all know that inherently but the
groupings here reduce the number of
elements in this composition to two or
three maybe four
um and and that's it like creating the
the um relationship between that Central
piece the secondary piece and those
those Corner elements is the only job of
the composition
um when I first started designing I
would put black borders around
everything thick black borders like this
you know just I I liked it
um it was my thing and then my boss who
was Czechoslovakia and said Jesus Christ
kid it looks like a [ __ ] death notice
and then I was like I had no idea what
he was what he was talking about
um and then I started looking you know
more in typographic history and I
realized in newspapers death notices
always had these big black borders
around them and a cruciform at the top
or a star and um and I yeah I ceased to
do it because I re I I realized at least
at that point in design history that I
was I was calling on something that I
didn't intend to but here it looks more
like um I mean the sort of danger in
this this thing is that it looks like um
it might be a poster frame that you buy
at Michael's like you could very well
imagine this on the Shelf in Michael's
just like this
um and you know the you take that that
piece out you put your your poster in
um but yeah I'm I'll sort of back up and
start where or end where I started which
is the we could all learn something but
this grouping of of objects on the page
generally speaking you you don't
necessarily want to repeat dimensions
and borders the page itself is already a
border and then adding a border and then
if you can look at the white space
surrounding the off-white that's another
border so it's just it's making the
space feel smaller unnecessarily and and
I think when we talk about like what
you're doing there with the words
deconstruction and
um and and the smaller type and how
you're pushing things apart I really
like that I wish you just played around
with that thematically a little bit more
and perhaps then we will run into other
issues because then things get really
complicated but I really want you to
push and pull type around and and really
do something with it to see what how far
you can push it before you can pull it
back and I think we're still playing in
this very safe space and it's quite okay
as a first exploration first time you're
getting feedback from anybody but
something that you might want to
contemplate into the future what I
really do like about this is and a lot
of Virgil's work you see the hand in the
creation of the work itself like how
he'll take the Nike Swoosh and and make
it shoot past the edge of the shoe so
you're like now become very aware of the
swoosh itself versus the ubiquity of it
all so calling attention to things like
that so having dimensional elements
having these blocks of yellow it almost
feels like strips of a Post-It note or
something
I think there's an opportunity here as
you tuck the word uh White above and
below that yellow block for you to
displace the type a little bit so it
doesn't feel so digital you know because
if that has form it's closer to US
versus the white which is further away
and to kind of have a little offset
there
again I think in this day and age with
the software and the tools that we have
it's so powerful that you're tempted
just to stay within it but this is
really you have to become aware like you
know what why am I working like this I
could do anything and there it's so easy
to do even if you photograph some
elements and you knew that they should
be displaced or offset that you would
just take the time and care to cut the
type and offset it so that it simulates
that look so if you're short on time and
materials I would definitely do that one
one really easy thing to terence's
comment about the the ribbons of type
which I think look really cool maybe
you're not getting the full effect of
those things just anchoring them in the
two corners but if the Shadows are faked
why won't you just print that out
cut it into strips and then manipulate
it and just put some tape at the edges
and then photograph that and then cut
and paste that back in so that the
Shadows feel right but then you're gonna
probably discover other things that
would be really cool I think of you
potentially taking this entire poster or
some kind of design sending it through a
shredder creating ribbons of paper and
then reconstructing in ways and then
maybe putting it on top of itself so
you're not shredding the whole thing so
there's a rhythm and a Cadence to it I
would have loved to have seen that and
that would have added so much to this
and and that that's all I have to say it
kind of It kind of reminds me of the
phrase like um if you're gonna break it
break it all the way so yeah this is
maybe not broken enough yeah to repeat
what Chris said yeah yeah so I think um
the theme that I'm seeing with the works
so far and we'll see what uh Charles
gets into next but some of you are still
I think uh on the edge of the pool uh
Glenn the water's fine just jump off the
edge and just explore and it's okay
that's it and as you're sharing I'm
going to show the original product piece
that the poster was based on yeah I
should have added those it's it's crazy
because I feel like I'm watching a
YouTube video because that's how I
always uh interact with you guys I'm
like wait this is live
so any thoughts or any responses or
anything that in in terms of what you
heard yeah I think the the talking about
the black border I think that's
something I always struggle with because
I think I think black lines and borders
they kind of bring bounce and anchoring
to peace but yet I think I somehow
overdid it here so I think I find it
challenging to find the balance between
anchoring something and also
giving it enough room to breathe in
enough enough space yeah I know what
you're saying you could try this next
time okay or actually try this on this
design take the black border scale it
down and rotate it and have it like live
over everything then the black border
has a whole different dimension in a way
of activating the rest of the design
give that a shot and maybe it feels like
it's maybe two or three inches above the
frame itself so cast a very different
kind of Shadow on things that might be
kind of cool is Terence are you gonna do
something here well I was about to I'm
about to try to crop this like on the
phone okay yeah I can but um oh wait
it's locked I might get myself into
making myself it's always dangerous when
you try to do things I know I know I'm
going for it yes do it I say live
dangerously so go for it
so I think what happens here is when you
get rid of the border the the whiteness
of the page can then feel like it's more
expensive versus boxing it in quite
literally with the Border I think I
think my the the where I thought the
black frame helped was to add like some
interdimensionality to the tape kind of
interacting with the actual frame like
the idea was to deconstruct and break
boundaries like to play with 2D and 3D
and kind of make them interact in a way
that kind of doesn't really make so much
sense to the eye so that was the goal to
kind of create a frame and then break
that 2D frame with the tape maybe
another way that you could have handled
the black border is to not have the
black border be perfectly lined to the
dimensions of the page just shift it to
the right and then and then all of a
sudden it creates some kind of tension
like what what happened why is it
literally now breaking the border so
play play with those themes
okay all right well thank you very much
Donnie sure um also fun fact
30 minutes after I submitted this design
my wife had a baby so I did I did this
in the hospital
congratulations yeah congrats giving
birth to design and and Little People
okay dedicated
absolutely
fantastic all right congrats
thank you